this is Gary Elle he's a single guy
living in LA and he's looking for love
these are nine sets of parents each with
a lovely daughter who might just be
getting Elle's future wife over the
course of three rounds
gotta yell we'll eliminate each set of
parents eventually picking one of their
daughters for a first date the catch the
daughters are all watching and as their
parents are eliminated they will reveal
themselves to the group and let gardial
know what he's missing this is stressful
y'all she's looking for a man who's in
it for the long haul you are gorgeous oh
I'm so sorry
[Music]
with an emotional rollercoaster right
now great to meet you all a little bit
about me my name is Gary otters larvae
I'm a veteran I work for busting I live
in LA and what I like to do is I love
dancing I dance a lot of Latin music
Simon and I love traveling I travel
every year I've been all over the world
because the military and also me being
the mini can travel back and forth to
the country a lot and what I'm looking
for in a girl is somebody a smart fun
that doesn't take personal some serious
you can put me in a situation we're
gonna have fun and we're gonna make it
happen so the first time you want to
date the person you see somebody's looks
since I can't see your daughters I'm
gonna use this room to take a mental
picture person number one is your
daughter pretty all right best features
her best because I would say would be
she's beautiful on the outside and that
resonates for the inside as well
ari has amazing divorce so you know she
has a great smile Gabrielle is a very
confident young woman and has these
gorgeous almond blue eyes she exercises
quite a bit she can keep herself up
physically but mentally she keeps
herself into doing by helping council
friends she is the head of gold she has
the most beautiful smile in the world
jessica is not only gorgeous she's
voluptuous and when she enters a room
you know other her presence is there
because she has a lot of energy he's got
the soft blue eyes pop you right in the
face the inside and the outside really
match up really well beautiful bubbly
personality and have big beautiful eyes
I covered an e-book
show me a baby picture they're all so
beautiful
[Music]
and it's hard because I you know it's
few questions we didn't get to know much
everyone but uh I mean five give me five
seconds I haven't been so nervous in my
life welcome to my show
dating everybody came in thank you for
doing this and it is a pleasure getting
to know everyone I am so sorry marry
Pennington it was the messed up part
about this whole process but good luck
have fun with the rest of the
competition I hope you can find someone
at least half as good as me the next one
I'm gonna pick
Tessa Maine was just like I had to pick
somebody getting personal what do you a
her are you about the most what is the
one thing that annoys you about Ariana
has two younger siblings and do you
think she's their mom we fight about how
to raise them they get away with
everything
she don't like for you that's it see how
her she stays on me about eating right
when she asked me for advice and when I
give her the advice didn't she argues
with me about the advice I just gave her
she keeps trying to convince me that I
want her to live far away from me and I
find that not in because
if she's meant to live far away from me
that's fine but I'm not ever gonna
really jump up and down and celebrate we
really don't argue to be honest with you
think I can really finish the other the
big fourth man our arguments actually
stem off that we do we argue about who's
receivers should be on the line which is
you know coaching we are very very close
[Laughter]
my first choice will be I'm sorry
Jessica Adams listening to all this
craziness thank you for joining having
fun with us on the Sunday yeah sure
thank you thank you it was tough
so the second elimination I'm gonna have
to go with NYADA and the reason why you
told me she doesn't dance I'm a big
dancer I love dancing I like when this
quarantine is over that's the first time
imma do what y'all want I'm disappointed
now okay so my parents apparel their
headphones so I couldn't hear what you
guys were saying but I'm kind of
cringing it was my third elimination is
I'm dream the reason why is your
infinite
I hear what you say okay three all right
so I have my family my sister she's
gonna probably make decisions for the
next round
hi everybody hi for this round we're
gonna need your daughter society for a
minute and focus on you being in there
from a good home seeing where they come
from my first question is and is gonna
be for Sierra what do you think a
pronounced boyfriend why didn't work out
with it so a little boyfriend wasn't his
family oriented that I like mmm has
something to do with the reason why they
broke up but to me family is everything
yeah family you know respect yes nothing
I don't have anything bad to say about
him I just don't think they were on the
same level Gabrielle has not had a
serious boyfriend for her I think long
term a serious relationship is about
really getting to know a guy just the
beginning and the solid foundation for a
real relationship that's what she really
wants she's looking for a man who's in
it for the long haul and that she can
just give herself to and can love and
love her back so I can say you sure you
should write a tinder profile
as you guys know I love music migrating
to the when I go on and a is the dance
so I would love to see you guys as moves
[Music]
who's ready to party
I am it is gonna be Albert even though I
know you guys are great
I love you guys like yeah we had to
choose somebody try to sell me hopefully
I see you guys around again but the next
one I'm gonna pick
I am gonna pick Marcy and I had loved
you guys personality yeah I love that
your daughter's an actor this latina but
she loves the fans screech I'm picking
you guys it was for Magnus my parents I
mean this was like all about the memory
both we are beta it's a top two and
there's a reason for that because
throughout the whole process I've
connected with you to the most is Aria I
love the Caribbean roots
you remind me a home you know you're
funny hoping that your daughter does
have your same person that Sierra one
thing I like about you you you do remind
me of my family in a way you from New
York your East Coast like me I like a
woman that's at the top rough around the
edges in a way and that's one thing that
you keep you keep reiterating because
that's the type of man I am
alright
you ready yeah Sierra this has been
crazy right beside I appreciate you
thank you very much you remind us a lot
of I said that so you know everything
that you said you we broke the same way
so it's just like I said it does feel
that we know you in a sense you are
gonna see a beautiful girl brother heart
mine I'm gonna tell you right now this
was fun for him this was fun for me I
thought was a really cool experience
especially in this quarantine you know
this is what we gonna do we're gonna
have buzz beep a party you know his horn
see we're in the middle of a corn sea
but we weren't if I take on the date
this little dude will go to New York
City
we're head of Brooklyn Bridge and then
after that we'll hit up the heights and
tried Dominican food all over like
Dyckman and watch the heights I'm a big
foodie and I love trying into its own so
down with that
[Music]